we're definitely there and support him  emotionally a one hundred percent Kris  Jenner and Kim Kardashian are not  worried about or scared of Kanye West  following his string of Twitter rants  this from a family insider who tells ET  quote all these reports about Chris and  the family worrying about Kanye hurting  their brand are a hundred thousand  percent false unequivocally false could  not be more wrong our insider tells us  Chris absolutely adores Kanye something  she actually said to eg last week he's  so talented and he's got such a great  vision and he's such an amazing force of  creation et source also says Kim and  Kanye's marriage is better than ever and  that any contrary claims are quote they  are so in love and Kim could not be  prouder of Kanye right now